Während deutschland der atomkraft den rücken kehrt investieren andere länder weiter in die. Kernenergie
Und es gibt eine neue deutlich sicherere technik thorium reaktoren sind sie vielleicht eine viel
Einfachere lösung zur klimaneutralen produktion von energie wie funktionieren diese reaktoren wie effizient sind sie
und wo liegt der haken herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Und danke für den spannenden themen vorschlag auf whatsapp, ein hochaktuelles thema anders als in gewöhnlichen
kernreaktoren wirtin thorium reaktoren nicht uran
Sondern thorium verwendet und das ist in der erdkruste drei bis viermal häufiger
Zu finden als hurra doch es ist nicht. Gleich für die. Kernspaltung verfügbar denn. Zunächst muss es erst einmal in das isotop uran. 233
umgewandelt werden das geht durch die aufnahme eines neutrons und weitere
zwischenstufen in einem atomreaktor das isotop uran, 233 spät besteht aus 92 proton und
141 neutronen lässt sich super spalten und liefert dabei etwa. So viel energie wie das natürlich vorkommende uran. 235
Mit dem gewöhnlicherweise die nuklear wirtschaft arbeitet doch der deutliche vorteile des uran
233 ist das weniger material im endlager landet denn es entstehen weniger
Hoch radioaktive abfälle der größte teil muss nur. Noch etwa 300. Jahre lang, hoch sicher gelagert werden
Wow, das ist wirklich. Ein hammer fortschritt, denn. Neben größten anzunehmenden unfällen
So genannten gaus oder super gaus wie in. Japan in fukushima ist orthomol ja das zweite riesige. Und bisher ungelöste problem der
kernenergie die befürworter werden nicht müde zu betonen dass thorium reaktoren
Energieprobleme weltweit lösen. Könnten und dabei sei das risiko noch nicht einmal besonders
Hoch im gegenteil denn in den flüssigkeits reaktoren in dem thorium verwendet wird das ist dort nicht fest sondern in einer
Salz schmelze gelöst und dies direkt auch für die kühlung zuständig die visionen waren deswegen schon, immer groß
Und zum teil sehen sie es heute noch der physik. Nobelpreisträger. Carlo rubbia hatte ausgerechnet dass eine tolle story
Um, so viel energie enthalte wie etwa 200 tonnen uran. Und das vorkommen reichen für mehrere. Jahrtausende
Doch, um, solche thorium reaktoren zu entwickeln wird es noch einige zeit dauern also diese sicheren. Und eine menge geld
Kosten ja und wenn es dann. So weit ist hätte das gegebenenfalls fatale folgen für die welt, denn
So würden dann nuklearwaffen auch in ländern verfügbar sein die politisch und gesellschaftlich eher instabil
Sind damit wäre die schwelle atombombe. Zu produzieren viel niedriger. Und es könnten deutlich mehr bomben in deutlich
Mehr ländern gebaut werden. Und es wäre auch für terroristen viel leichter an sie
zukommen indien besitzt zum beispiel große thorium verkommt und möchten die kernkraft stark ausbauen
Um innerhalb kürzester zeit unabhängiger von uran, importen zu werden auch china ist an diesem ziel. Dran insgesamt will die regierung in peking
3,3 milliarden us dollar ausgeben. Um
zwei thorium reaktoren in der wüste gobi zu entwickeln dazu die south china morning post
Die technologie kann, theoretisch. Mehr wärme und strom erzeugen als bestehende form von atomreaktoren die, urahnen verwenden wären sie nur
ein tausendstel
Der radioaktiven abfälle produzieren die reaktoren sollen unterirdisch. Gebaut werden. Zwölf megawatt soll die erzeugte wärme erreichen die
Dann, zur stromerzeugung dienen soll aber auch im militärischen
bereich
Ist diese technologie für china höchst spannend geplant sind kriegsschiffe die solche reaktoren in sich tragen einige experten und expertinnen
Warnen schaaf vor der entwicklung der thorium reaktoren weil sich so eben auch neuartige
Atombomben basteln lesen ja schon im kalten. Krieg hatte man. Herausgefunden dass sich uran. 233
hervorragend als bomben stoff eignen würde somit warnen einige
davor dass thorium reaktoren zur produktion von waffen material genutzt werden
Könnten als eine sorgenfreie atomenergie der zukunft kann, man
Thorium reaktoren aufgrund dessen auf gar keinen fall bezeichnen sie würden die erde, zu einem deutlich unsichereren ort machen wenn
Er keine videos zur entwicklung in diesem bereich. Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann tötet mich bei whatsapp, denn
dann verpasst ja absolut kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt
Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und ihr habt die
Unzuverlässige youtube abo box ausgetrickst, und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs
um
Social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Glocke vergessen genau hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken. So wäre ein atomkrieg bis. Dann
bleibt dran